what's up guys so there's this new
infinity edge water from dome called D
del s 2418 H which is revealed just
earlier this year we're gonna open the
box and see what's inside
so simply comes open just like that
there's another one over here as well
[Music]
okay once you got that open
so on this first gray bar you got the
stand then but the speaker if you got
the age version if you got the inversion
you wouldn't get
about some power adapter cables power
brake and an HDMI cable it's nice that
they give you an HDMI cable it's a lot
of modern story
finally at the very bottom is the actual
[Music]
so shiny so this has has a very glossy
screen so you guys sit in a very bright
area you can right now - monitor but if
you're not sitting in such a bright area
that this is definitely the way to go
because this esse so much better than
call it accuracy at representation
assembly instead is also used for this
water so simply just get instead
thank you
[Music]
it's over
the Fosters
[Music]
there's a little slide right here
here looks like make sure
[Music]
there we go
got the feature
[Music]
here
this thing right here it flex for
Angeles
first I'm gonna play this game where you
go straight through here
flood right here
[Music]
and down so I got that I can
here is to Delhi as 24 mph
[Music]
this 24 inch longer is quite possibly
one of the most beautiful screens I've
seen it's almost best list display and
gorgeous mirror like finish almost make
you forget that the monitor is only
1080p and 60 Hertz while these specs are
average or lower for gamers these
numbers are absolutely acceptable for
people Amy tears their monitors for
productivity or media consumption in
fact the nice glossy screen combined
with HDR makes all the colors pop it
makes the image of bright colorful and
dynamic
while these features are nice let's talk
about price though prices monitor at 290
dollars but you can always find this
monitor for $200 on Amazon or other
third-party vendors like Best Buy in
fact if you guys are considering this
monitor you guys should click the link
down below for Amazon to buy this right
now because monitor is how only a
hundred fifty us and Amazon right now
that's right almost half price that
price puts this monitor in line with all
its competitors while offering a
splendid design in an array of extra
features the nice angular shapes and
small bezels makes it an aggressive
design without being obnoxious and it's
30 great metal stand a nice classic
speaker give it that classic download
it's overall important it's very sturdy
and more than enough for the average
usage its bezels measure in at just five
millimeters on the sides and top of
eight known ears on the bottom this
monitor sports a 23 2016 5 IPS display
with a resolution of 1920 by 1080
the panel comes with and advertised six
months I've been a great degree response
time and a default refresh rate of 60
Hertz on top of that it also has HDR and
a MV of greasing supported the golf kia
skin reflects everything like a myriad
of life situations put in the dark
and in areas away from light this
monitor produces a jaw-dropping image
with its 99% coverage of this RGB color
gamut the monitor only has a small Dell
logo at the bottom and I think we can
all appreciate that what did the
on-screen menu users can change their
input source Browns through some presets
play around with the aspect ratio
sharpness response time and personalize
the energy use and audio input and of
course you just can change the
brightness of the monitor this monitor
displays a very bright image and I often
find myself lowering it to fifty or
seventy-five percent of this maximum
brightness the four simple buttons make
navigating through the options of breeze
and dirty position under the monitor
keeps them from being an iceberg the
only complaint I have with the buttons
are that they are somewhat difficult to
press and I often find myself
reinforcing them monitor to the top in
order to press the button but otherwise
the user money is well crafted the back
of the monitor is also glossy and is a
fingerprint magnet however with periodic
maintenance the back looks done
unfortunately the stand does not support
movement and there is no base and
mounting options either force you used
else given standard but throw is the
possibility of triple monitor miles away
but the small bezels are still perfect
for triple monitor setups albeit not as
clean for the rear i/o you'll find an
HDMI 2.0 input VGA input audio a line in
and out a speaker port and of course a
power input unfortunately there is no
display port while this monitor is
obsolete splendid it really is not a
game of wonders it's really meant for
good color reproduction within a
nice-looking structure finally last but
not least this monitor does come with
duo 6 watt speakers built within the
stand these speakers are nothing
compared to educated speakers but they
are one of the best monitor speakers I
have ever heard
here take a look
[Music]
speakers actually get quite loud without
signing ting but my only complaint with
them is that when they're on their
maximum setting they produce static when
there's no sound going through them for
wonder around lower settings there's no
static so there's no problem then but
when they're on the maximum setting
there is static or even when there's no
sound so many things up here there is a
lot to love about this monitor it's
infinity edge display slick design and
dynamic colors are just a few overall
while this monitor is not built for
gaming this monitor is a great buy for
the average user especially given its
current price point it's absolutely
perfect for media consumption and daily
work tasks as well if you're looking for
the best specs then listen on for you
however if you're looking for a great
monitor with a slick appearance for a
great price and this is a great bike
this is also a perfect for people trying
to set up a sick triple monitor set up
virtually no bezels well work
application such as Adobe After Effects
or communica overall this is the best
looking monitor I've ever seen and
viewed as a perfect bike for casual
gamers and people using their computers
for school or work there are also other
variants at Dell makes of the same
design or similar designs such as the
Dell as 2014 18 H which is the same as
this but just to being just bigger so
those are also worth checking out if you
guys are looking for better resolutions
or a bigger display Harbor those do come
out of price premium so make sure to
keep that in mind while you guys are
looking for that perfect monitor that's
going to do it for now guys if you have
any talks leave it down below in the
comments below and if you guys liked
this video make sure to like it and if
you guys loved it make sure to subscribe
if you want to see more videos just like
this until next time bye